there's one thing one thing that if you
did every single day no joke it would
make an extraordinary difference it's
really easy to isolate yourself what I
want you to do is I want you to actually
make a more concerted effort to reengage
every one of us has an internal fuel
tank that is either empty or full and if
you're empty you feel depleted wanna
soar get a mentor
[Music]
so today let's learn from one of the
best Mel Robbins and how to deal with
stress anxiety and depression mentor me
mouth
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one exercise if you have depression if
you have anxiety if you have
post-traumatic stress disorder if you
have any kind of mental health condition
it's nothing to be ashamed of and it's
nothing to hide and it's something to
hit head-on with there's one thing one
thing that if you did every single day
no joke it would make an extraordinary
difference in whatever mental health
issue you're struggling with and that is
exercise and the reason why I say this
is not based on my own personal
experience it's based on the fact that
the I think it's the American
Psychiatric Association this is coming
from dr. John Ratey a friend of mine who
has written a ton of books about not
only ADHD but also the benefits of
exercise and what it has on your brain
but he's also a professor at Harvard and
a practicing clinician and this is his
area of expertise and one of the things
that they now mandate as a diagnosis for
anybody with depression or anxiety or
any mental illness frankly is you've
gotta exercise every day and the reason
you've gotta exercise every day is
because what we know about human beings
is that when you physically move your
physiology changes and that changes your
brain getting your heart rate up getting
outside breathing feeling connected
getting out of your house which may make
you feel depressed and trapped doing
that every day that physical push you
don't have to run you don't have to go
to aerobics Pat's class get outside with
your dog in the woods
walk with a good friend for two or three
miles doing that every single day not
only moves your body which changes your
mind it gets you out of your physical
environment which is one of the things
that people with depression tend to have
a hard time doing and it also creates a
bit of momentum and a bit of a routine
in your life you take on just that
single thing get outside and exercise
every single day as if your life depends
upon it because you know what it does
your brain needs it your body needs it
your mental health needs it rule number
two
see your friends more it turns out that
one of the best stress relievers on the
planet is something that most of us
don't ever do and that is seek out time
with friends when we feel totally
stressed out when you're doing twice as
much work as you normally do or you're
feeling twice as much stress as you
normally feel studies at Harvard show
that what you need is you need to see
your friends twice as much now
Sean anchor is a really famous
researcher and best-selling author at
Harvard and he studied this phenomenon
he looked at at people that were
stressed at schools and in call centers
and in the military and in banks and in
almost every single industry what he
discovered is that the most successful
people the people that were the best at
selling the people that there were the
most resilient the people that had the
best ability to deal with stress when
times got tough were the ones that saw
their friends the most it was the people
with the tightest social connections
that had the ability to weather the
storms that life throw at us
the takeaway is really simple it's
really easy to isolate yourself what I
want you to do is I want you to actually
make a more concerted effort to reengage
we don't talk about the isolation piece
a lot I bet you have friends right now
that are super stressed out that you
haven't heard from and maybe even a
month and the reason why you haven't
heard from them has nothing to do with
you it's they're doing what we all do
they're isolating themselves and guess
what they need they need you they need
more connection and that's exactly what
you need when you feel stressed out too
so here's my challenge for you I want
you to write down three people three
people that when you hang out with them
you feel energized that when you have
plans with them you're excited about
seeing them when this video ends reach
out to them that's right pick up the
phone send them a text I want you to
invite them to do something go out to
lunch go for a walk in the woods get a
cup of coffee go out to dinner even if
you're not stressed out I guarantee you
at least one of the three people that
you're going to reach out to needs you
also if you want to build confidence
like Mel Robbins and other successful
entrepreneurs check out my free to 54
series the link is in the description
below if you didn't give a [ __ ] what
anybody else thought what's the thing
you would love to be doing with your
life when you have an intention on
something that you want to change about
your life your brain helps you you might
want to get honest with yourself I can
study doing this be a billionaire or do
this
do you really because you can make it
happen
you actually can look at all the idiots
that are making money you can make money
rule number three use anchor thoughts if
you've got to do something that really
makes you nervous or that you're afraid
to do before you're about to do it come
up with an anchor thought what's an
anchor thought well an anchor thought is
something that's going to anchor you so
that you don't escalate any situation
into a full-blown panic attack or into a
situation where you screw things up it's
a way for you to anchor yourself so you
maintain control over what you're
thinking and how you behave so here's an
example with flying it's important when
you're creating an anchor thought to
pick something that is in the proper
context of what you're afraid to do so
for flying pick an anchor thought that
has to do with the trip that you're
taking so if I'm boarding a plane to fly
back home to Michigan an anchor thought
might be a picture in my mind of my mom
and I walking on the shores of Lake
Michigan where I grew up that's a
thought that makes me happy it makes me
excited and it's also related to the
trip that I'm taking if you have a
conversation that you need to have with
your boss pick an anchor thought about
how you feel after having that
conversation maybe it's you picking up
the phone and calling somebody that you
you love and saying oh my gosh it went
so well or you know you walking out of
the meeting and feeling like yeah I
survived that conversation I feel pretty
good about myself so now that you have
your anchor thought you're ready to beat
the fear how you're going to do it is
this so let's go back to the example of
the plane I'm on the plane i'm flying to
michigan we hit turbulence my body's
going to start getting agitated right
I'm starting to get nervous
how it starts to race one of two things
can happen I can't control how my body
might feel but I can always always
control what I'm thinking about and I
can always control how I act and so can
you so when I'm on a plane and the
turbulence hits 5 4 3 2 1 that's step
one and it's essential and the reason
why using the five second rule 5 4 3 2 1
is essential is because that is how you
switch the gears in your mind you awaken
your prefrontal cortex and you trigger
your brain that you're now in control of
your thoughts you've interrupted the
fear you've settled your thoughts and
now your brain is ready for that anchor
thought so then what I do after I go 5 4
3 2 1 is I insert the anchor thought
that I've already come up with before
the flight I start thinking about
walking on the beach and being with my
mom and my dad and I start telling
myself I'm so excited to walk on the
shores of Lake Michigan I'm so excited
to see my parents
now something remarkable is going to
happen in your brain because you've
interrupted the fear and because you've
used the five-second rule to assert
control and awaken your prefrontal
cortex and because you have an image
that can textually make sense to your
brain because you're flying to Michigan
you know your brain does your brain goes
huh
that was excited to go to Michigan
because my body is in a state remember
the first fact fear and excitement exact
same thing what's the difference between
fear and excitement what your brain is
saying using the five-second rule in an
anchor thought you can actually switch
the gears in your mind and reframe the
thoughts of fear into thoughts of
excitement and because you have a vision
that makes sense based on what you're
doing your brain buys it you just
tricked your brain and rule number four
the last one before a very special bonus
clip is make decisions that energize you
I believe that passion is another word
for energy that's it
what do you have energy for what
energizes you and that we naturally have
a tremendous amount of body
wisdom about that and that every one of
us has an internal fuel tank that is
either empty or --fill and if you're
empty you feel depleted if you're full
you feel energized and so if you simply
are in any situation I mean any
situation and you pay attention within
five seconds to does this person
energize me do they deplete me where are
they in the scale you just gain some
tremendous wisdom and you the simple way
to start to figure out who you are and
what you want is start aligning yourself
with more things that energize you so
situationally if you're lying in bed and
the snooze alarm goes or the arm goes
off and you feel depleted and you start
reaching for the snooze button that's a
really big sign that you need to get out
of bed now being depleted versus
energized has nothing to do with whether
or not things are hard or easy it has to
do with what naturally actually either
expands you or shrinks you and so if you
look at your client list and measure it
depleted versus energized what shrinks
versus expands me you have the actual
map and when you start to find the
courage to make decisions that energize
you and that expand you whether they're
scary or not that's when everything
changes and so that's how I actually
make business decisions is this I don't
even like the money conversation comes
second it's does this deplete or
energize me and if it depletes me how do
you move it in that direction or how do
I stay sane oh if it energizes me how do
I do more because if you are energized
or expanded by something you will do it
for no money you will do it happily and
you will suddenly wake up and say oh my
gosh like my heart I'm pursuing my
passion how did that happen
and I've got a really special bonus tip
for male talking about how depression is
lying to you that I think you're gonna
enjoy but before that it's time for the
three point landing questions let's move
from just watching the video to taking
action in your life for business here we
go
question number one what decision can
you make right now that will energize
you number two what's an anchor thought
you can create for yourself every day to
stay motivated and number three which
friend can you book a time with to see
this week you see the thing about
depression that's really difficult is
that the depression itself lies to you
it lies to you and says you don't feel
like doing the things you know you need
to do and we buy into that line that's
not to make you wrong it's because
depressions really good at convincing us
we can't do it and so the interesting
riddle about depression is that in order
to beat it in order to live with it in
order to make sure you don't let it win
you're gonna have to learn how to push
yourself to take action even though the
depressions lying to you that you can
feel like retreating and you can choose
not to what are you getting out of this
as soon as I get that feeling in my
stomach or the feeling in my head I just
count 5 4 3 2 1
right go for a walk pick up the phone
post that thing do not like you're gonna
win this one push one action at a time
you got it awesome
if you want to learn from Ella how to
make this year your best year ever check
out the video right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there
attention economy if you haven't heard
it you're gonna start hearing it a lot
I believe that passion is another word
for energy